[موسيقى]
كارثه مصرفيه قد تطال البنوك الامريكيه في
حال لم تقدم اداره الرئيس جو بايدن حلا في
اسرع وقت بدات مع ازمه افلاس بنك سيليكون
فالي والتي تعد الاكبر منذ الازمه الماليه
العالميه عام 2008
ازمه اس في بي ادت الى هلا بين المودعين
في البنك ليتجهوا الى سحب اموالهم دفعه
واحده بينما اصول البنك لا تكفي لتغطيه
جميع الودائع فالمبالغ التي تكون ادنى من
250 الف دولار يغطيها تامين للسحب الفوري
من قبل مؤسسه تامين الوداع الفيدراليه
لتبقى بقيه المبالغ في البنك
ضغط المودعين على سيليكون فالي ادى الى
انهياره ما دفع الحكومه لاغلاقه بجميع
فروعه والاتجاه الى ايجاد حل لانقاذ اموال
المودعين
الخوف الاكبر ان تنتقل العدوى الى بنوك
اخرى مشابهه لسيليكون فالي ما قد يؤدي الى
كارثه مصرفيه حقيقيه ونزيف في تمويل قطاع
التكنولوجيا والشركات الناشئه
مصادر من البيت الابيض اكدت ان مسؤول
اداره بايدن يقيمون تداعيات انهيار البنك
تجنبا لتاثير افلاس اس في بي على بقيه
البنوك
يبقى الحل معلقا حتى يوم الاثنين الذي
يجتمع خلاله البنك الفيدرالي الامريكي